Двічі на день Драган Зрдоц витягує свої сіті, якщо сприяє погода
Як і його батько до нього, а ще раніше - його дід.
Достатньо кількох ударів весел.
Раніше їм ніколи не доводилось виїжджати далеко, адже в бухті Котора було повно риби.
Була риба - багато риби! Ми ловили зграями. Сайду, білу рибу і хамсу.
Але це в минулому - зграй тут більше немає!
Винуваті, вважає Драган, вони - круїзні лайнери, які причалюють перед Котором.
Їх стає чим раз більше.
Майже щодня один або кілька цих гігантів швартуються біля маленького причалу міста
і випльовують тисячі туристів.
Котор в Адріатичному морі є для круїзних кораблів одним із найпопулярніших місць,
таких як Венеція та Дубровник.
Але поки вони вже давно тиснуть на гальма, оскільки стільки туристів їм більше не підсилу.
Кількість пасажирів круїзних лайнерів продовжує безперешкодно зростати.
Зрештою, кожен турист витрачає тут в середньому 40 євро.
Тут це єдина можливість для процвітання туризму.
Багато людей з цього живе! У Которі немає пляжів, у ньому немає навіть готелів, на жаль.
Одноденні туристи забезпечують бізнес у Которі, але він - нестійкий.
Це розуміють і в місцевому турбюро. Утім, відмовлятися від бізнесу не хочуть.
Щодо Котора, справжню різницю склало б будівництво великих готелів.
Із однаковою кількістю гостей ми забепечили б вищий дохід
і одночасно спричиняли б менше збитків.
Адже ми говоримо не лише про проїздні кораблі, а й про інших одноденних туристів.
Однак, концепції відсутні, і ЮНЕСКО, до чиєї спадщини належить Котор,
вже била на сполох, тому що біля бухти велося некотрольоване будівництво.
Та Драган скаржиться, що тепер у небезпеці знаходиться вся екосистема бухти.
Це пустеля, тут втрачається вся біорізноманітність!
Як тут може вижити дрібна риба або навіть риб'яча ікра,
якщо вона наражається на такі сильні течії.
Завжди, коли гіганти причалюють чи відчалюють,
вони використовують кермове управління на носі та на кормі.
Вони діють, як величезні міксери, які сильно перемішують воду в бухті.
При цьому "Коста Вікторія" належить ще до невеликих.
По-справжньому великі кораблі, такі як "Майн Шіфф 6", тоннажністю сто тисяч тонн,
стають на якір посеред затоки.
Вони годинами перевозять своїх гостей до берега посильними човнами.
Для чутливої ​​екосистеми затоки, говорить морський біолог Весна Мачіч, - це катастрофа.
Поки що комплексне поєднання солоної та прісної води ще якось тримається.
Морське середовище може триматися довго - воно може відновлюватися, але є межі.
Коли ця стабільна система руйнується, відновити її надзвичайно складно.
Процес вимагає тривалого часу й великих коштів. Коротше кажучи: я боюся того, що гряде.
У затоці якір підіймає "Майн Шіфф 6" і при цьому знову збурує тонни мулу.
Шлях із затоки веде через вузький канал. Його ширини саме вистачає для проходу велетнів.
Для туристів - розвага, для морського біолога - кошмар.
Неможливо собі уявити, що станеться, якщо якийсь корабель зазнає тут аварії.
Насправді, каже Весна, бухта Котора вже давно має бути заповідником.
Адже морські заповідники є обов'язковими, якщо Чорногорія хоче вступити до ЄС.
Кожна країна повинна охороняти 10-ти відсотків свого узбережжя.
Тут це означає - приблизно 30 кілометрів.
Чорногорія вже 10 років працює над деякими проектами,
які повинні стати морськими заповідниками, але заповідників у нас усе ще немає.
У бухті залишилось лише жменя рибалок із сотень, розповідає Драган.
І якщо ситуація не зміниться, додає чоловік, його покоління рибалок у Которі стане останнім.